we need your help to fund the resistance
our pal Alex Jones knows exactly what
I'm talking about we need financial
support you know the globalist rappers
on every front we make it easy to deal
with really high quality the best water
filters the best air filters the best
t-shirts to spread the word and ball
caps super know about talent percent off
we've got the probiotic my own defense
50% off you pour that in on a couple ice
cubes and folks it tastes when it's
creamy and thick I think better than
Ovaltine and it is got all the bone
broth and so much more this is why the
ancients they believed we had such
better bones or so much healthier you
look it up yeah yeah exactly
our ancestors were healthier I mean not
in terms of life expectancy but in terms
of not living long enough to get
divorced yes healthier you freethinkers
have been sending Jones your hard-earned
cash at least 18 million dollars a year
but we also need your support to defeat
the globalist that's why next week you
have to ignore all the corporatists
Black Friday sales and instead support
the opposition and our very first all
lives Friday sale will have discounts on
all of our high quality products and you
can check out the website right now at
shop addition.com people you need this
stuff to survive don't listen to the
brainwashed authorities who say that our
products are snake oil unless they're
talking about our medicated serpent balm
which is in fact mostly snake oil all
lives Friday will be packed with serious
deals for serious threats folks you saw
the elections you saw him last week our
country is drowning under a blue wave of
Democrats but yeah well you're scared
too you can fight back with seeing red
are a hundred percent hydrofluoric acid
drops that give your eyeballs a red film
so the world looks just like Trump's
electoral map quack doctors will say
this crimson filter is just capillaries
exploding in your eyeballs I say it's
the truth exploding in your brain also
we're going 50% off on liver trainer the
isopropyl alcohol formula that challenge
your liver to step up or shut the down
and we are nearly out of stock at our
amazing pro-bender
microorganisms to make your gut health
smarter stronger and better at finding
restaurants on Yelp ladies and gentlemen
you have to go to shop ization dot-com
mother's father's even kids it's never
too early to start opposing am i right
Laura absolutely Jordan children are
under attack from progressive toys look
Sally Ride and three other women all
NASA pioneers are being honored with
their own likenesses the women of NASA
lego set went on sale this week and it
quickly became the top-selling toy on
Amazon did you see that Jordan female
Legos are taking away male Lego jobs
like pirate and Han Solo
what's next genderless toy people that
don't even have the best part of the
Lego the genitalia no no screw all this
Danish gender-bending we need to get
back to good old-fashioned american
blocks bricks let me tell you Jordan
my kids love these they've built tons of
not up to code structures and still have
so many fingers they haven't broken yet
Oh incredible that's incredible shop
addition.com products we can literally
rebuild our republic the old life's
Friday sale it's the only way to prepare
for what we all know is coming later
this year the apocalypse that's why I'm
stocking up on apocalypse survival packs
filled with the essential products that
the best Preppers demand non-gmo
bandages a coal powered hot plate
miniature Confederate monuments
pepperoni supplements decals that make
sticks look like laser guns and the
complete collection of trumps tweets
that will become the new constitution
when society rises from the ashes and
that's what this is special and if you
order tonight I'm throwing in this
exclusive private bathroom which comes
with an additional guest bathroom
guys this clueless this deal is crazy
you have to buy now or you will perish
later we don't know what's coming for us
opposers robots demons city bikes who
knows you need products to fight the
battle and the best way to fight the
Liberals is to trigger the get out of
them and Aaron and Josh have just the
thing yes we do Jordan the kale males
will freak out when they see you wearing
our super sturdy 25 thread count Texas
cotton t-shirts with cut baiting phrases
like God hates facts and Judas was a
live yeah at shop addition.com you can
get a whole wardrobe that says I believe
in free speech more than I care about
being allowed back into this grocery
store or we have a capelet with the one
phrase guaranteed to make the kombucha
chuggers bleed from their ears and
shriek from their eyeballs Austin Powers
3 is Beyonce's best word it's literally
a statement piece hey and just because
Jeff Sessions won't go after Hillary
doesn't mean your ass can't yes yes that
ass won't quit and neither should a
special prosecutor look bottom line I'm
not exaggerating your family friends and
country will crumble into a pile of
trash if you don't support the fight at
chop position calm and in return we
promise to keep fighting until every one
of your dollars is gone